l'architecte du brds excite le cerveau
du référendum de 2016
elle les surnoms sont nombreux pour
qualifier dominique cummings 48 ans est
conseiller spécial de boris johnson
depuis vendredi deux journaux
britanniques qui l'accusent d'avoir
enfreint les règles de confinement des
informations erronées selon le principal
intéressé comme je les dis je pense
qu'il ya une colère compréhensible mais
une grande partie de cette colère est
basé sur des reportages dans les médias
qui ne sont pas vraies et c'est
extrêmement regrettable mais les médias
qui rapporterait certaines de ces choses
qui étaient erronés ont été informés
qu'ils avaient tort
mais les ont quand même signalé le
conseiller aurait avec femme et enfants
ont parcouru 400 km pour rendre visite à
ses parents alors qu'il présentait les
symptômes du kobe 19 selon les services
du premier ministre une histoire de
garde d'enfants expliquerait ses
déplacements il est raisonnable et juste
de demander une explication à ce sujet
et cela a été fourni deux parents
atteints de corona des russes s'occuper
avec inquiétude de leurs jeunes enfants
ce qu'ils cherchent maintenant à le
politiser devraient se regarder
longuement dans le miroir mais voilà la
nouvelle passe mal outre manche la
sphère fait la une des médias les
politiques même issu de la majorité
critiquent l'attitude du conseiller
spécial du côté de l'opposition
accueillir ce tram heures à chef du
parti travailliste parle même d'une
réelle trahison le premier ministre a
traité le peuple britannique avec mépris
une règle pour dominique que wings une
autre pour tout le monde
en conférence de presse sous dimanche
boris johnson a tenté d'éteindre
l'incendié
pour lui dominique que mills a agi de
manière légale et responsable une
indulgence est difficilement
compréhensible dans un pays où
l'épidémie de coronavirus a fait plus de
trente six mille morts